welcome to this video yeah this will be
the first episode of a serious that I'm
going to start and this will be called
modern classics
um the criteria for the seriousness that
I play I show you games that have been
played in the last let's say roughly 25
years and yet it's supposed to be a
selection of the the most interesting
best most instructive whatever you want
to call it games of this time um yeah
the selection of the timespan is some
yeah mostly because um I'm thinking
about the time for which I play a chess
myself which is about from around 25
years so these are games that are really
yeah experienced right after they have
been played so when you look in a chess
newspaper and see a new game or back
then we have we only had newspapers we
don't have had the Internet of course
and you got really stunned by new games
that have been published that have been
just been just been played okay the
first game that I'm going to show you
this um a true classic and I fear that
most of you might know it but it's still
such a magnificent game that it should
be really part of this the serious this
is from 1991 and the players are the
city von Schuch playing white and Otto
Yusupov playing black at the time um
even shock was oh yeah the prime
candidate for becoming the new world
champion remember 1991 was 21 years ago
Yvonne Chaka stiller yeah top ten top
ten player nowadays back then he was the
clear number three in the world behind
Kasparov and Karpov and he was destined
to become the new challenger really but
he faced their outer Yusupov here in the
candidates matches so this was for young
for the fight for the World Championship
match
and you support is a very very tough
opponent so today if he's quite an
inactive nowadays but back then he was
really tough opponent very tough to beat
and the true fighter he just that two
years ago was very close to beating
Karpov for the spotter to fight Kasparov
in the World Championship
he was very just an inch close of
beating Karpov so not easy and this some
candidates match played in Brussels 91
Yusupov actually was behind before the
last game but managed to beat even shook
in the last game so they had to play
rapid playoff this was a bit new at the
time to have those playoffs
nowadays we used it but back then it was
new and they played a 60 minute rapid
games to decide on the match to rapid
games and this was the first rapid game
so it was really of utmost importance
so not a game played in some weekend
tournament where people are relaxed
drinking cocktails it was really for
everything right so um let's see this
game even shook remember had lost the
last game in the in the normal
tournament games and it was the first
rapid game so he kicked out one C for
use of plenty 5g 3d six I won't go into
much detail about the opening because
the game is really so complicated that
we need time later and I don't want it
to be two hours you can easily make a
three-hour video about this really okay
we got a King's Indian by some unusual
news water and it's very unusual for you
to puff to play the King's Indian is
mostly been a Queen's Gambit player on
this life but here you went for a
sharper opening and he one shot being a
bit surprised opts formed a side line
with Quincy to rookie one not playing
efore himself and okay it's a pretty as
we see a positional somewhat
somewhat slower kind of development but
now he is putting some pressure on the
six and you support me advances it spawn
here too he formed winning space and
this will be yeah
the most important piece if you want in
the game this upon and we see what
happens not g5 attacking of the pawn and
like to push his own so this was
obviously I'm a development that Iran
shock had foreseen it was easy to to see
that and he answered with F form and
yeah now we got a position where White
has you to space it warranted she was
his pawns and pressure on d6 though he
also has ideas of advancing the b-pawn
and the checking on the queenside he
also has this great Bishop so white has
numerous positional advantages here but
what black has is he's got this pawn and
in this pawn is already near the White
King and might be supported or might be
the the key piece that supports other
pieces near the king and here we got
immediately a very sharp battle use of a
flop late night to f8 before and Bishop
f5 this was the idea of not FA to
developed the bishop with tempo Queen
went to b3 and now aged six an idea
three and Knight to g4 so we see that
black probably wants to go to F 2 with
this Knight which is just a single piece
it's not checkmate but it looked
threatening to have the night near the
king and he also intends to play g5 to
attack therefore pawn at this point is
only supported by g3 so g5 96 let's say
here oops no here then there'll be some
pressure on f4
black has definite counter play but
white is very quick on the Queen side we
see B v g5 now even shook took on c6
and plate now I'm a very controversial
and aggressive move remember it is a 60
minutes game so they didn't have four
hours to to make their decision I think
if you look at the game later it must be
it must be really hard to play this with
the short-term control even much of not
at 95 which really puts yeah more oil
into the fire really using this pin so
that black cannot take on e5 the queen
is attacked by the bishop and this
Knight instantly attack c6
but on the other hand this night also
yeah moves away from from white skin
it's it's perfectly okay this move but
it needs to absolutely razor-sharp play
Yusupov took on f4 there's not much else
he needs to break through on the Kings
side the night took on c6 and Dark Queen
g5 so the Queen it goes into attacking
position probably intending Queen to h5
or using this position of the king and
queen on the G far yeah here white took
on d6
which looks really like a logical
continuation it also attacks the f4
Hornet in a way this Bishop also
protects the King side what had an
alternative you could also think about
the very direct move each for here and
this probably needs to check very
unclear consequences some at least them
if you have limited time to analyze
Queen h5 of course still intending to
take and then white um has two ideas he
can play Bishop d6 again or I could play
complain Knight to d5 with the intention
of giving a check here with one of the
nights and then queen b5 we can see a
central line here if black would take on
g3 then white would give this check
King moves and queen bee father this is
the idea to have this pin on the Sun
from the from society on the
fifth-ranked
but yeah black can take Queen takes f5
and then Knight to g6 like simply keeps
attacking and this line flee funny
enough at the end it's probably a draw I
could continue this it's very very
complicated
probably the simpler solution for
bloggers to in this position Queen h5
Knight to d5
just to play not g6 and it's really
totally unclear like threatens here here
but the white also has this various
counter place Bishop d6 Knight to e7
it's a lot at this point but the ideas
are there and it's totally unclear so h4
was a viable alternative but I think
mostly you have to decide them via on
instinct of course calculation is super
important in this kind of positions but
sometimes you just need to make a move
and hope that your instinct tells you
the right thing okay he took on d6 I
think I I think I would have this
position at most probably what would do
this also simply because of the
additional defensive ideas of this
Bishop move okay Yusupov played Knight
to g6 covering f4 and you see now there
are lots of pieces attacking the King
and it's obviously dangerous but White
has completely cleared the coincident
would simply win if it weren't her
checkmate umm 96 I want the only move
actually like also could have think
about kanthamma taking just sacrificing
here and this is quite interesting if
white would now take on h2 Queen takes
two three king edge 196 we see that
black has
very strong attacking ideas and you can
continue this line Queen b5 as a
possibility attacking of the bishop and
also intending probably Queen to d5 in
order to protect him
one thing is black can simply draw here
so their various draws possible in this
night takes a ch2 line in fact them even
here before 96 black of course can can
make a draw if he wants with the
perpetual so on this taking on h2o
directly allows the draw not sure what
what I would have done the problem is
you allow a draw with white but still
black has some alternatives that give a
strong attack it's probably probably
it's a very probable that he wouldn't
have taken but maybe go for a move like
Bishop takes a form which looks also
better from a defensive point of view
securing this pawn but this is also
completely unclear black might go here
intending to just drop back and then
give the check and this after Knight d5
is a total mess again black might go
here and a sample line which illustrates
the danger is this for example if white
would give the check here group takes
this kind of line very greedy then this
one would happen threatening checkmate
on f2 Bishop here you should be form and
it's over like will mate once King white
only has some spy check on d8 and black
can't cover this if he takes now we've
got this checkmate and yeah Queen h2
Queen G to miss checkmate awful
threatened
note that this pawn plays them super
important role in all of this it limits
White's King so
the some alternative taking on h2 was
certainly a good idea but Yusupov really
played the most shop moved possible he
just tried to strengthen his attack with
96 and now white played 95 going for a
counter-attack there's simply not much
that he can do to defend the King he
cannot bring any pieces over there this
is mostly due to the pawns especially
the e3 pawn which really cuts the ball
into two halves that's really the King
start where black dominates and the
Queen side where all whites pieces are
or the center and this is really the
remarkable thing about this position
that those pieces are placed so
aggressively in the center but they
really have a tough time defending so 95
first mentioned was played until you've
played Queen to h5 he also could've
taken again on h2 it was still an
interesting line in fact white only has
one line to to make a draw him he can
lose in various ways though the drawing
line is quite amazing move very hard to
tell if he would have found it
for instance what is losing yes sir
Knight takes here this this actually
loses and I can show you how the the
problem is that take here Knight to g6
discover the tag then black can play
just this with the idea we should be
formed
and this is in fact impossible to defend
what should what should why do let's say
here and it's over
still note the very important on its
some simply a deadly attack so so the
move right should players probably queen
b7 and I say probably probably and yeah
you just need to look at the position I
mean it's super difficult to to assess
this kind of this kind of this kind of
game I really invest a lot of time to do
a yeah new Anna to new to do new
analytical effort on this simply because
the old notes that have been published
at the time are simply not usable
anymore I mean there can they contain so
many mistakes which now can be easily
found with the computer I mean it must
be hell to to analyze this completely on
your own and let alone play it ok but
let's look at what what might happen
after Queen b7 black can't play here
Knight f3 check and this secures to the
draw one line is Bishop f3 coups no
Queen g3 check and now of course white
cannot interpose with the bishop because
of this move and it's over checkmate
should made to come with Queen g2 so
white needs to move the King and jetsam
it's a perpetual check black also cannot
win because white always has this count
of threats here with with 97 and the
rook hanging at the end so it cannot
really invest some waiting move on
whatever he needs to do something
forcing um you can look at the pawn take
here on on f3
after which black also captures and now
threatened again with the knight H for
our bishop
to a tree so wide also um okay this pond
with maybe also so I'd really need to
get going here cannot make any slow move
and what you should do is give this
check him after which black must capture
with the rook he would take both the
night there's simply this and now yeah
black black has to move he loses almost
all his pieces and it's simply no
checkmate at the end you look at this
there's a check here and at the end
white white protects it simply a crazy
line of course I mean crazy to calculate
so in fact after 97 black needs to take
with the rook and then it's a it's
actually drawn if white would take here
King age 7 this should be 7e to node if
black would try this then there's this
amazing defense and it just holds its
still okay for lucky can he can go here
amazingly threatening this this and all
kinds of taking moves e to Bishop d4
it's an intact still a draw I could you
can continue this if you like but for
the sake of length of the video I'll
continue um it's simply crazy
complicated so how did we we get to get
to this this was the alternative to take
on h2 which use above didn't play he
went for Queen h5 which is perfectly all
right yeah okay that's the threat term
here and whiteness no choice he needs to
push the pawn on lung h3 there's simply
this movement g3 will fall
so he needs to go here and here um
Yusupov actually commits a mistake but
okay it's very very easy - OH - to make
a mistake in this position you can't
really talk about mistakes because it's
so complicated that even if you look at
what the superstrong computed will take
a long time to really figure out what's
going on here um he took on h4 which is
quite an obvious looking move blasting
open the kingside what in fact if you
look at this later from a theoretical
mathematical point of view but the
computer it's probably it's not the best
move what he could have done and what
probably needs to draw as taking on g3
the idea is if white recaptures on g3
then you take here and you continue the
attack armed with pieces and it probably
will lead to a draw a sample line is
Queen to g5 it would be five sorry the
idea being to use the fifth rank again
and now like and play captures on g2
Knight d7 Mars are very complicated King
h8 Queen takes f5 and Queen f3 and like
simply continues to attack what should
why do now let's say he plays some a non
forcing move would be one for instance
then there's oops then there's this move
this is black thread he takes the Queen
and friends check made and if Y takes me
there's this checkmate yes so this is
the threat white cannot make a slow move
because of this night h4 idea so on the
move two players the forcing move Knight
to e5 attacking the g4 night and now
like and secure the draw the means of
rook takes is seven queen g4 queen g4 9
takes g4 and at first you think okay
like it's lost right this piece doesn't
have any square but in fact there's the
magical move Knight H form it's simply
amazing intending to go back note that
from a material point of view is equal
after all this fireworks is equal okay
what can take but then you've kept Ruby
form this is the only saving idea and
this funny enough leads to draw a
possible line is here here all right f5
rook F for Queen g7 and now the very
important move rook to g8 and this gives
black enough a tick and not enough
activity to draw the game for example
here black was threatening checkmate
Jana rubgy seven rupees g7 Andrew Paige
forest checkmate so I needed to to play
this move to cover this so work g7 King
2 H 2 H 4 look h3 rook default this will
end in a draw of course and insane line
nobody can calculate this it's 25 moves
deep but ok
so F takes G for was probably right but
okay it's impossible to see why this
move shouldn't be good so you need to
just go by instinct in a in a rapid game
yeah white needs to take it - not much
choice
Queen takes yeah and in this position
which is really the the critical
position rather one of the critical
positions of the game here on Shogun
yeah made a mistake but this is all
relative um the move that would win now
is very similar to the one that he
played he played Knight d2 to e7 check
the winning move however as night c2 is
Sam check okay I'll show you some lines
but of course it's as mentioned almost
impossible to calculate this the the
best try for black is King h8 Knight
takes f5 at first you you won't think of
this is complete nonsense but like has
ideas it's not like it's totally easy
Queen h2 King f1 and at first you might
think okay what is happening here what
are black said yes he cannot go to to h4
with a queen to threaten mate oops to
threaten made on f2 so what is blacks
attacking idea here and in fact in this
position he has an absolutely stunning
move we should be five what's the idea
of this move the idea is you want to rip
open the G line the G fall to UM to get
a meeting pattern in the end I can I can
show you how the the idea is white for
instance takes here it says the system
just to show the idea
black takes oops I'm sorry rook takes of
course rook takes D takes d5 rook g8 and
this is the idea that black has in this
position the idea is to sacrifice the
Queen on h1 so white would make nothing
move let's let me just show it move like
this then there's this move Queen
sacrifice check King e1 and rook g1
checkmate and this is the most important
motive in this game this checkmate like
is trying to set up this checkmate with
the rook here and the pawn is just the
rook and the pawn against all White's
pieces and this is what black is trying
to achieve with this Bishop e5 move he
wants to clear the G file for this idea
so Bishop e5 what should why do we can
look at two moves first especially Phi
which which I already has started to
show the problem is that in this
position where I just showed if what
happens if white makes a nothing move
white in fact has still a defense he
needs to eliminate the e3 pawn but this
is not quite enough if it takes here in
this line just the Queen f4 check and
black still has a strong attack let's
say here here and this in fact is enough
to to win the game Group G to check King
e1 check again
and it gets gets very ugly now oops I'm
sorry I confused I need you to go Neto
need to check here first this line Queen
default check and so black is winning
if white would go here then you have
this King SEOs what what's this thing
doing Queen King c2 now and now of
course it's simply Queen to be to
checkmate yeah very neat so returning to
the position taking only three is not
enough but wide in fact has an amazing
move to save himself with Knight g7 the
ideas and this is totally amazing if
black takes now it's a check on b8 king
here check on b1 and now between here
and this in fact yeah
leads to a draw at the end if you look
at this black now can can can fight on I
mean okay this is a winning tribe like
black and of course just drop back this
is the draw after white give this check
but black cannot play for wind with this
because of Queenie form yeah yeah it's
so complicated I'm confusing myself here
so let's return to this amazing Bishop
e5 resource in fact white can can win
the game here with D takes e5 this this
secures win the point is if now Rob g8
then on white actually can do this
counter sacrifice
and you will save himself the idea and
this is impossible to spot simply is
after taking here White has to move east
six attacking the Queen and also and
this is the main issue it prevents this
mating pattern because you can simply
capture the Queen otherwise this would
still have one so this is six resources
the key resource here of course
no human can spot this it's simply
impossible and it even wasn't spotted in
analysis after the game it's only when I
looked at it now with the strong engine
you can find those resources it's
impossible for human to do so return to
the game position so that we don't lose
the threat altogether here there's check
ideas only seven we just looked at this
night see to the soundcheck which in
fact after looking here and now this
resource the the toughest try by far
loses after this move but it's it's not
possible to see this I was really need
to be realistic here also you can try
various other ideas here if you we have
at what should back to it only has this
move and then there's simply discounted
sacrifice if life takes now here by the
way you can take take care that it's
protected and now after this wide simply
protect g2 and there's no attack at all
Queen here Queen f3 so night c7 would
have won the game but impossible to to
thing out really so if one should give
this check which is very similar but of
course it's still a difference we see
what happens now King h8 took on f5
check on h2
King f1 and now we see a difference like
now played the move rookie six in fact
this is also only the second best move
in the position just to get it get it
right and show the the the most likely
the best play the here was an
alternative Bishop to f6 and this is
probably even stronger but it's also
super hard to figure out of course black
already has sacrificed to pieces yeah
it's not like he can he can do a simple
you know maneuvering game here but this
move is actually very strong and the
idea is very slow its Bishop to h4
bishop f2 and then Queen g1 mate and
surprisingly it's a very difficult for
white to do anything again this um there
are still these ideas of route g8 also
so this idea and rook g8 with this
mating idea that I showed which already
was Queen h1 so they're both these ideas
if white would go here for example then
route g8 wins already because you cannot
parry this it's simply over can continue
the line but even Queen d5 doesn't help
it's still this checkmate checkmate
still amazing so white can drive route
d3 trying for a counter sacrifice of
course you can already return lots of
material because yeah you've got quite
some some extra material already so in
fact if black now would play rook g8
then white can do this counter sacrifice
based on on this pin note that the rook
only three killed the pawn so you cannot
go Queen h1 here
there's simply a new square for the king
but in fact instead of rook g8 black now
can go for this other attacking idea and
amazingly rookie 3 now bishop f2 I mean
this position these positions are also
they look out of her chest study it's
it's it's really amazing that this
happened in a high-level a serious game
ok this was not on the board but the
general does the kind of position that
we got here
what can take here rook takes and yeah
you must believe me black wins here this
attacker sir is too strong a possible
line now oops
with threats of discoveries and it's
it's impossible for white to save
himself another another cool move yeah
we should you one check amazing if white
would take now then black takes here and
this made mechanism wins f queen f2 and
e 2 and e to check so white needs to
step up here and then you you really got
got lots of checks going the next the
next hammer blow and if Knight takes
Knight takes you must go here and then
we have a mate coming up Queenie 223 and
it's it's made soon we're estimate the
Daniel Isis ready Quincy to check right
oh yeah this is this right so King King
a three-night see form yeah nice King
and so let's return
where were we even yeah this was the
came this was the game position and
where I just showed that Bishop f6 would
have been strong you should have played
another move a very understandable move
I mean it's not like I'm criticizing
here I just want to show the
alternatives because there's so many
great lines in them so rookie six he
played and this idea is quite quite
similar to the one who's already he
wants to go g6 and then set up this this
mating mechanism and here white could
draw this is why Bishop f6 was stronger
you should have six M was a yeah winning
from black but now white actually has a
drawing chance but this is insane
simply insane to see he played Queen b7
and this move loses because of one of
the most amazing technical sequences
that I ever saw but what would would
have drawn here is rook d3 and the idea
is if like now goes route g6 then you
have this rook III idea and this is what
saves white in fact there's a ton of
alternatives but this disinfect is
enough to save the day using the pin and
with also this point now the queen is
attacked and a possible continuation
would be of course some black needs to
to move the Queen here and then this and
the white is perfectly okay but even
this is hard to see from material point
of view is okay and there's no huge tech
anymore the Queen can help and whites
still has this very strong pawns and
centralized pieces Knight f7 also
friends so Luke d3 has this idea to to
save in fact this even would win so rook
g6 wasn't even the best move what black
can do is he can take him and secure a
draw
because now is threatening checkmate and
white only can go here and then it's a
perpetual yeah
impossible the thing is I think a von
Schuch he played Queen d7 and simply
thought he would win this game but what
happens now is simply simply astonishing
no use of plate they absolute hammer
blow rook g6
I mean you most probably after I've
shown the the idea of the checkmate you
you probably have suspected this this
Queen h1 idea but wow there's a rook
Humphrey and why took it oops not this
one of course he took the rook with
check even and King him and even here he
would think all right there there's not
much going on white is so much with
material up I mean he's got all his
pieces left yeah like a sacrifice rook
and two pieces so if one should probably
saw this but he now played this move the
only move to prevent the checkmate this
is the main thing thing and okay black
needs to take check here King to h7 here
here and look at this position white has
two rooks and three minor piece and
black only two minor pieces left so from
material point of view it's still
perfectly alright he now took and maybe
I don't know maybe even at this point
thought it would win the game but black
has a simply amazing resource and this
is the the stunning move Knight to f2
with the idea of Knight H Street
threatening checkmate on g1 I can show
you if what doesn't nothing move like
this it's not h3 and you know I have
this checkmate threat white has no way
to prevent this if he takes it
then there's this checkmate with the
lone Queen and the pawn on e3 against
all white pieces and it's simply
stunning so white has no no big choice
he needs to make this desperado
sacrifice I played this yeah black black
just took it and they're still of course
this configuration is still intact so
after white now played Knight to g6 he
returned to a tree and still has this
idea and it's simply nothing that white
can do what he tried still has rook to
d1 983 check on 7 here yeah and now
there's no check rook b8 I mean it's
covered young white gave this check as
the last kind of move Queen takes bishop
takes and Queen g3 and it's checkmate
next move and that's it so it's a great
that the end of the game is the
combination just of those two pieces
Black's Queen and the the hero of the
game the pawn on e3 delivered checkmate
at the end so an absolutely fascinating
and astonishing game in fact them you
might know the famous chess publication
a chess informant on which has been
published I think since the late 60s and
when they did when they had their I
think 13th 30 year anniversary in 1996
am made a porn poll my problem I know
yes so I really for among the readers
what what should be the the best game of
all chess informants history of 30 years
and this game won this the readers chose
this as the best game of the last 30
years in 1996
so yeah simply spectacular I'm always
really enthusiastic look at the lines in
fact I did about I don't know one or two
hours invested to to do some computer
assisted analysis and if you want to
have some fun take this game give
yourself some time do some analysis on
your own if you want but if you even
have you simply feed it to the computer
and try to figure out the different kind
of lines
it's simply fascinating this what I
attached you and this 45 around 45
minute video is just the tip of the
iceberg there are so many great lines I
just showed some of them really okay I
hope you enjoyed it the series will
continue with other classics also with
games that I might outstanding but not
so unknown I realized that this game
it's known to many people but I will
also show some that I really enjoyed and
that are not so well known yeah I hope
you liked it and yeah talk to you soon
with new videos